protests like this in kenya have become
frequent
this time they're speaking out against
the rising cost of basic food prices
many people here say life has become
unbearable
and a general election in august is
making things more difficult
julia
is a casual worker on a good month she
earns about a hundred dollars so every
coin counts
she says the cost of her basic supplies
have doubled in the last few months
we're struggling to make ends meet may's
flour has doubled cooking oil has become
unaffordable my children and i have
adjusted our food rations so i can
balance all my needs
voters are electing a president mps
senators governors and other electoral
seats
politicians are using this campaign
season to promise that they will fix the
economy but many voters are not
convinced they say they are delusioned
and they don't trust their leaders
economies say a new government will find
it hard to lessen the burden for most
people
this is partly because of a huge public
debt
much of the money has been borrowed from
china for large projects like this
expressway some government officials
have also been accused of corruption by
inflating costs whoever takes over as
president
this is the devil's breakfast
you have just ordered the devil's
breakfast
we are almost hundred billion dollars by
the time they take up 100 billion
dollars
in public debt
we're now borrowing
to pay
interest on previous borrowing
back at monyony's family home she
prepares a basic meal she's behind on
her rent and school fees she's running
out of ways to make more money she tells
us she's living in incredibly desperate
times catherine soy al jazeera nairobi